well today is moving day at Los Angeles
International Airport the world's fourth
busiest airport is used to seeing some
220,000 people take off or land on
nearly 2,000 flights every day but
tonight many airlines will move LAX will
begin one of the largest terminal swaps
in history and an active airport fifteen
airline airlines are relocating over
three nights six have already moved Kris
Van Cleave is at the airport's Terminal
five Chris good morning good morning the
signs are up and they're hoping people
are reading them it starts at midnight
tonight and pretty much everything has
to go from the kiosk to the sign all of
it because the new airlines well they're
already starting to move in they realize
it could be confusing for Delta the
airline could be operating out of up to
four different terminals the question is
in the morning of matric will you know
where your airline is at LAX chances are
it's not where you left it 15 Airlines
will be packing up and moving to new
terminals over the course of just three
nights and they've got to do it in the
roughly five hours between when the last
flight arrives and the first one in the
morning starts boarding six other
airlines have already moved it's a race
against time that took nine months of
planning this is a major disruption to
this Airport Keith will sheets is the
airport's deputy executive director of
operations
it is incredibly large and complex we
are unaware of any airport who has ever
tried something this massive in terms of
moving Airlines 21 Airlines over the
course of just a number of days it's
essentially the same as moving Midway
Airport Delta is footing the entire bill
for the move it'll go from terminals
five and six to roomier digs in two and
three part of the Airlines 1.9 billion
dollar renovation project one of the
busiest airports in the world that was
1963 when LAX handled just 20,000
travelers per day today passenger
traffic is ten times that the airport is
now in the middle of a 14 billion dollar
multi-year modernization project to meet
increasing demand they're upgrading
terminals adding gates and connecting
the airport with a new light rail system
we know these will be a painful few
years as construction relocation Transit
comes in but when we
are done this is going to be one heck of
an airport the airline move will involve
220 workers nightly with 10 trucks
moving everything a carrier uses at
gates ticket counters and lounges
including 300 offices and 3,000
computers nearly 1,000 signs inside now
need to be changed we're not expecting
everything to go perfectly but at the
end we want everything to be in place
and we want our passengers to feel like
they're glad that we did this and we
didn't have any major problems
bottom line you'll want to get here
extra early and there will be hundreds
of volunteers on hand to help Gail so
focus on the end game you'll be glad
that they did that thank you Chris